في ايسلندا وفي العاصمه ريكيفاك تحديدا
اصبح للحمم البركانيه بواجهها وحرارتها
معرض من دون خطر
في هذه القاعه التي تشبه الصاله السينما
يعيش الزوار تجربه فريده من نوعها
بالاضطراب من تدفق حقيقي للحمم المنصهره
على الساحل الجنوبي منذ 140 سنوات لذلك
ناخذ الحمم الصلبه التي اندلعت منذ فتره
طويله ونقوم بتسخينها حتى نقطه لنصها ثم
تذوب ثم نسكبها
وسط قاعه العرض اقيم هيكل تصف على جانبيه
عواميد وعلى المقاعد القابله للسحب جلس
نحو 40 زائرا غالبيتهم العظمى من السياح
الحمم المتوحشه
بالرمال السوداء
فتضيء القاعده كما لو ان الشمس اشرقت فيها
وفي اخر المنحدر يصدر السائل المنصهر عزيز
ويتصاعد منه عندما يبرد صوت يشبه صوت
الزجاج المكسور
ومع ان الرائحه المميزه للحمم البركانيه
حاضره في العرض افقدها تسخينها المتكرر
غازاتها السامه مما يتيح للجمهور الاقتراب
منها اكثر مما قد يفعلون لو كانت حقيقيا
فكره اقامه هذه العروض استمدت من قمه نهر
جلدي ومن بروده الثلج الى حراره الحمم
البركانيه ولدت فكره رائعه
جعلت من الخطر عرضا